foreign
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast on the show today is the lovely
and beautiful Leanne Rhymes she has sold
over 48 million records she has two
Grammys and 12 Billboard Music Awards
and the list seriously just goes on and
on and on she has a new album out called
God's work really I mean of course I
would love to help her promote it
because the album's amazing the wild is
my favorite song If you want to know
really she's just she's just really open
she's spiritual she's deep she's
introspective and those are all really
good ingredients for a good conversation
and someone that can help others and
truly what you'll learn is how much she
wants to help there's so much more than
just the music to her she has a lot of
stories to tell and a lot of lessons
that she's learned and she's dealt with
everything from anxiety to family
Dynamics relationship Dynamics today on
the episode she shares so many of her
lessons it really resonates I got
goosebumps many times throughout the
interview just with sort of that
Universal yes there's so much truth in
this and there's so much power so I hope
you feel it too please enjoy the episode
and if you like it please hit subscribe
and the bell for notifications and I
always love to read your comments on
what resonated with you thank you for
doing this by the way of course to talk
to you I feel like you're such a you're
such a you've had so much life
experience and you you know you've gone
through so much stuff and and you're
just deep like there's just it's just
fun to talk to somebody that
contemplates things that
um is introspective that does the work I
mean it's just not always super common
it's true I love having these
conversations they really fulfill me in
so many ways I love going on podcasts
like this because it's I don't know it's
just I don't I don't have these kind of
conversations every day you know and
it's um I don't know it's just nice to
talk talk to people of like mind and
like heart and
yeah get into get into life yeah life I
mean that's really what it is like
contemplating life okay well first thing
to like talk about is we both just
turned 40 this year so oh you did too
yeah my birthday was March 25th and
yours was just a couple of few months
after right yeah July August 20th August
yeah yeah okay so I feel like it's sort
of uh it's it's a mark in time so were
you dreading 40 were you excited about
40 what was the vibe with 40. I was
excited about 40. I actually enjoy
a new decade and I've always enjoyed
turning older because I was so young
when I started and people made such a
big deal of my age and no one ever
wanted to let me grow past 30. so I feel
like 40
felt like I was really stepping into my
Womanhood
for the first I mean I felt like these
last five years of my life I've really
been stepping into my Womanhood but
really at 40 it was kind of that mile
marker for me to really allow myself
to feel
fully a woman and I was yeah I was very
excited about it but now I don't I don't
feel any different like nothing changed
I was waiting for some like big moment I
was like oh no that was nothing happened
what does feeling like a woman what does
that mean I think I just allowed
there's all there's many things there
um yeah I I feel like I'm a better
there's a there's a mothering piece for
that for me like I'm feeling like I'm
taking care of myself like taking care
of my child's inner child self
um where I feel like I've really taken
on the responsibility of that
um I don't have children of my own I
have two stepsons but and I one of the
reasons why I've never had children is
because I I didn't I've had so much
trauma in my life and also generational
trauma passed down that I was just like
I don't I don't want to bring a child
into this world until I know I can
I can do it differently now at 40
thinking about that I know I would I
could do differently now and I don't
know that door hasn't completely closed
but
um for a long time it was just this I
absolutely won't pass down what's been
passed down to me and um
you know I didn't want the
responsibility either of you know being
of of mothering in that way
um because I didn't feel I didn't feel
prepared and now I feel like I'm doing
it for myself
um and I've taken on that responsibility
and it feels it feels really good and I
I also feel like another piece of that
is
you know really just
being
sourced and driven from the inside out
instead of you know external validation
being the most important thing and I
feel like that like not giving a [ __ ]
more and more has really like 40s really
kind of given me
um
I don't know even more depth in that
area of just really feeling
internally sourced which is nice yeah
well I I would imagine a lot of that
comes from the caretaking that you're
doing because I resonate so much with
that like mothering yourself and you
know
too much of a long story but part of my
sort of trauma has related to obviously
mom and dad but the mom and really that
element being that needing to have my
own back because she didn't necessarily
have have me emotionally taken care of
and yet that's only because she didn't
have her she wasn't doing that for
herself so I was just that pattern which
would put me into a pattern of being
with the wrong people that didn't take
that didn't take care of me right but
that was okay because I abandoned that
anyway so
um right so what what do you feel like
what are you doing what are you doing to
take care of your inner child what are
some of those little activity like
messages or practices because I feel
like this is sometimes for some people
this isn't this is this kind of sounds
weird or it doesn't make sense to them
but maybe when you articulate some of
the things that you do and some of the
decision making that you do differently
now it might make sense what you're
talking what what what is actually
happening
yeah I mean I look at myself as you know
a whole being of you know all of these
different aspects of mental spiritual
emotional physical
um well-being and
how am I filling those up every day you
know am I giving myself rest
um am I
you know taking care of my physical
health has been something that I've kind
of put on the back burner for a really
long time and I I grew up with psoriasis
as from the time I was two and if I
wasn't I thought sickness was kind of
just a part of my life and always would
be so it's almost like I gave up on
feeling any better than just okay
um and you know six six to eight months
before I turned 40 I was like that's got
a shift so I started taking care of that
aspect of myself and I think I just look
at all of those buckets every day and
I'm you know am I am I giving myself
what I'm needing in those areas of my
life and I prioritize that like I you
know I think the biggest thing is
prioritizing myself
um and my care and you know being in the
business that I've been in for so long
it's been
on in constant motion I have been the
center of it all it's been me but at the
same time I haven't put myself first
it's been everything else has come first
so I think I have started to recognize
like I have I have needs
um and I I want to feel good and you
know really I think the rest piece for
me too is like I said as much in motion
as I've been my whole life rest has not
been something that I have even felt
comfortable with right like I just took
a nap before we got on here for 30
minutes I was like I feel so good so I
think it's those things I think it's one
thing I've been doing you know for my
own mental well-being too and and the
Child In Me Is You Know pick one thing a
day that makes me really happy and I
love going on a bike ride I love I have
used to love jumping on a trampoline
when I was a kid so I have a rebounder
that I like will jump on for 20 minutes
and it's just any any like 20 it could
be 10 20 minutes like anything that just
uniquely brings me joy
um
I really try to focus on one of those
things today especially when I'm really
really busy during my day
um so it's so simple like there's really
simple things
um it's just the commitment to them and
being consistent with them and I think
that that adds up at the end of the day
was there were there things or a way of
being when you were a kid that you
really weren't allowed to do or be and
some of it might have been direct but
some of it might have just been an
energetic like motion of stuff that was
happening
um I I mean I was an only child you know
I was a pretty blonde girl in the South
like you know and I was raised Southern
Baptist and there was always this idea
of
um Perfection and you know as an only
child who grew up in a very volatile
household
um trying to take care of everybody's
feelings
um I was you know I was a performer and
so
and that was a way to make people happy
and so I I think I I learned
I had this idea for so long I'm still
working on it now that I'm bad like
growing up you know and like I said in
in church where we're all told we're you
know Sinners and you know and I have
organized religion has its own place and
I it works for some people but for me
there were just these really underlying
you know very sad messages that I very
much internalized and
um
and I'm still like that's one of my deep
core beliefs that I I carry around that
I'm that I'm working with is I you know
I'm bad
and
um you know so I I didn't really I
didn't I didn't have a chance to I think
fully be me like without
trying to fit into everybody's box
around me that what they the idealized
child and not like the real child so I
think now I've
you know loving
all the complexities of myself is such a
challenge I have to allow those messy
parts of myself to
to have some play time
um because I wasn't I don't really think
that that was and you know I don't think
a lot of people around me were
um aware of any of this but I those are
the messages I I received as a kid and
and very much internalized that those
things that happen when we're kids are
so influential and they might not always
be direct words but they're just a
feeling of like you know maybe even you
were going on tour but you were off like
playing with Barbies or you were like on
the swing set or something like that it
was like get back here and so it's like
you're bad because you're not doing
whatever you're supposed to be doing and
those things leave
such deep deep inference we obviously
share the same share a doctor which is
super fun
um so I want to talk about that Health
stuff you know as you said you turn 40
and you know you work on those things
and psoriasis and I didn't know that is
it fixed and like what have you learned
about that what have you learned in that
realm because man that's a giant rabbit
hole oh yeah it is a rabbit hole and I
feel like I keep going deeper and deeper
down it like every day
um yeah it's uh I don't even know where
to begin there I why'd you go like why
did you I called Mindy Mindy because I
wanted um I wanted to work on my
hormonal health so I had I had been on
birth control for years as so many women
are
and yeah it was awful and um
one day I decided to just take myself
off of it and I
my body kind of went right back into its
normal rhythms but not really like it
was it was kind of a yes and no I had
periods but then I don't think my all of
my hormones were balanced and sinking up
properly and
um no one had ever taught me about
hormonal Health at all like we're not
taught any of these things as kids and
so like I said I knew going into 40 in
this new decade I know there's a lot of
changes that we go through as women I
got on the phone with her she's so funny
she's like oh sometimes I when I work
with celebrities she's got like I
thought you know I'm probably gonna get
on the phone with her and talk to her
like for you know 45 minutes and and
that'll be it and then literally I've
been boxed out of box with her like
every day she's become like one of my
dearest friends and we found our way
into each other's lives and I honestly
I've never had someone walk me through
Health in such a profound way and you
know it's gone from hormonal help to you
know healing my gut to
um working on thyroid stuff like to
um yeah just figuring all the pieces of
the puzzle out and you know I've
discovered so much about my body that I
didn't even know and you know having
psoriasis from so young there's so much
inflammatory stuff there and
um no my psoriasis isn't um we haven't
really gotten to the root of that but I
feel like we're through other things
we're getting to the root of what you
know might have triggered that as a
child so
um yeah it's a you do open Pandora's Box
and you know there's days when I'm like
oh I can't do this anymore I'm getting
so close to feeling
um you know even better and I've come so
far like I actually keep a list of you
know of
little markers that I see of how I'm
hearing and I just started to do it yeah
I just started doing that recently
because it's so easy to lose sight of
yeah the tiniest of transitions that are
happening and um yeah I've uh I've come
a long long way in eight months and and
I'm I'm still on that Journey so
yeah I wanna I wanna feel good in my 40s
I mean I had this goal I was gonna like
look and feel my best when I turned 40
and instead it was the [ __ ] opposite
and I'm like
oh God I mean truly the word the
opposite
um what is your what's made the biggest
difference well I have to say one of the
biggest things
um I have a oxygen chamber here in the
house and that has that's changed me a
lot
um I have I can tell the difference in
my brain
um I can tell the difference in my mood
um that is it's definitely a game
changer for me especially when I come
off the road like to just try to get
back into balance and you know back into
normal life so it's um that's one of the
most profound pieces and I'm I'm not we
don't have a sauna here which I'm really
digging the sauna like that when I when
you start learning about like I've
learned about all the neurotransmitters
and when you start learning about what
does what and you know know I'll be in a
bad mood and I'll get in the sauna and
40 minutes later I'm like oh I feel a
lot better like all the serotonin and
dopamine and everything starts to like
wait till you get the cold plunge too I
just finally got mine delivered and I
was in it for about five minutes after
the sauna today and my body was um numb
after that it's 45 degrees is what I've
decided to set it at and like then like
as the blood comes back it's like just
blotchy like your whole skin is like
looks like you've been sunburned but
somehow patching back together again but
yeah those things can be super powerful
I have a hyperbaric as well and um God
damn it I just can't get my ass in that
thing I it's it's hard it's hard you
know what the trick for me has been is
going in it even for like 20 minutes at
a time because that that that was a
Mindy trick man he's like because I was
the same way I'm like I'm so anxious in
this damn thing she's like just pop in
there 20 minutes at a time and so 20
minutes became like 45 minutes then 45
minutes sometimes is like an hour and
then I'm like oh it's not so bad so I do
it in the morning first thing when I get
up so I'm not like I don't have a lot of
energy running through my body and that
seems to be my key to at least getting
in there every day yeah yeah maybe
that's a good idea just get in there for
20 minutes which basically means
pressurize and depressurize right right
that's true you talked about anxiety and
I know that that's a part of your life
and
um like I'm curious like I think I feel
like we go down a pretty deep dive on
just the mental side of things and just
you know where did that come from and do
you do you know where where that stems
from because this is this is an area of
life I'm I'm really interested in and I
really want to understand
um better because I'm I'm a bit of a
first-hand learner and I've owned I've
had a couple couple times like three or
four times
actually about three times in my life I
felt true anxiety because I knew I
couldn't escape the thought it was like
a like you couldn't choose a good
thought it was like heart racing more
um and actually when I was doing such
heavy detoxing with Mindy oh that's like
Who full dropper fulls of that like
brain blood-brain barrier stuff a day oh
yes doing like suppositories ever
recital yeah Saito I was doing two full
droppers a day oh my God positories
every night yeah and like every other
drug every other like pill and every
other modality including like red light
in the Hyperbaric and the sauna and the
you know like I just stacked a million
things and I finally hit a wall because
she said let me know how your mood's
doing and I've just got this like weird
resiliency and I was like fine I'm fine
I'm fine I'm fine and then all of a
sudden I'm like I'm depressed yeah like
I'm like I was literally depressed and
so I kind of just stopped doing
everything but it's such a it's it's
such everybody pretty much everybody
will deal with it on some level but some
of course deal with it on a really
regular basis and I just have so much
empathy
um what's been your excavation of that
energy oh there's so many things
um funny thing about Saito I actually
you know I'm I'm of the thought if one
works then two must be great so right
and so I she's like just do like five
drops of side out to like you know slow
and then I'm like one dropper full and I
was in the fetal position because it was
all the that mercury it was like coming
out of me which Mercury causes so much
anxiety which I at one point had a
heavier Mercury load which was
definitely feeding that
um so yeah I feel you on the side oh
um I I think there's multiple sources I
actually just went to Dr amen and did
the whole brain skin how would you think
I was fascinated it was very interesting
it's very interesting to see my brain
um I have like zero dopamine going on
when I I'm not taking I take medication
um for
um it's called Vyvanse which is a
stimulant because at one point I I just
I basically get into these free states
of low depression and where I can't move
and so I take a very low dose of it to
get me out of it and he did a brain scan
one uh one on it and one off of it and
off of it I have like zero dopamine so I
think when my dopamine Pathways were
being created as a child I was wearing
those things out left and right and so I
my body just doesn't right now doesn't
create it on its own
um so it the the medication actually
really helps my brain go from having
this really sleepy brain to actually
being
um so good yeah it is Andrew huberman
really dives into dopamine really well
I've listened like stuff yeah
um and but the the thing about the
medication too though it really
activates my basal ganglia which is my
whole anxiety issue so are that's
already very activated in me and that
just kind of multiplies it but so I have
there's there's it was great to see
reasons why I have this kind of free
state
um depression and then this anxiety I
also have a lot of like some pretty
severe PTSD in my brain from just life
and so I think that's part of it too
just trauma that you know is still in my
nervous system that I'm working through
now
um so I feel like I've I feel like I've
gained a little bit more clarity around
what's going on with my brain
um which for me is really helpful
because I don't feel like there's
something wrong with me it's just like
oh this is now I have a clear picture of
what's going on when when my anxiety is
activated I know what's activated in my
brain and so
I am and I through all his testing I
realized I have a very strong negativity
biased toward life
so you can see that he can see
well
what's that we took like it's there's
like a there's a whole thing of the
measuring you know yeah all the
measurements yeah I have a super strong
negativity bias and so I've literally
now for the last I guess it's been about
two weeks I have a morning routine of I
do
um a Kundalini meditation called kirtan
Korea
um which is like 12 minute meditation
um that's supposed to really activate
your frontal lobe so do it working with
that I'm working I have a gratitude list
that I do morning and night and I
actually think of things that I'm
grateful for it and then I let it go and
I like I sit in that feeling of it
um I have been really focused on like I
said
um I have that list of of things of ways
that I'm noticing my body and my mind
and things are changing
um I was watching Jonah Hill did a
documentary uh recently about him and
his his therapist I I can't recall his
therapist's name at the moment um it's a
fantastic documentary I highly recommend
it but in this I just watched it last
night and I started this practice this
morning and I love it
um he talks about putting putting the
next Pearl on the string and
he was saying that no like that mean
meaning if you got up and got out of bed
that's a pearl of the string if you
brushed your teeth that's a pearl on a
string like if I did this podcast it's a
pearl on a string and so
um it was no no pearl no one no no thing
is good or better than the other thing
so it's like basically you just get up
every morning and you're gonna put a
pearl keep putting pearls on the string
and I started a list this morning a love
list because I'm a Virgo
um I started on the list this morning of
like how I'm noticing like all the
things how I'm putting my pearls on my
strings today and it's great because
it's helping I'm noticing all these
little things that I'm doing or really
helping train my mind to look for
um look for the good look for positive
it's positive reinforcements positive
reinforcement of my healthy habits and
for someone that has a really strong
negativity bias and also likes to live
in the future and plan everything which
causes a lot of anxiety
um and out of the present moment I think
all of these little tools so simple
really kind of helped me focus on
what's good in my life and I've been
doing
like I said these little practices for a
couple weeks and I can I can tell a
difference like a major difference
that's a really good practice
um and uh for a Virgo for sure I have my
son is in the sixth house which is Virgo
and so I am very uh empathetic of Virgos
because well there's two very dualistic
sides to a Virgo yes one is that one is
that you know there's a lot of aspects
but one is that you really truly
accomplish really incredible stuff
really incredible but the ver but the
other side of it is is you don't really
see your own greatness and you don't
really tend to give yourself credit for
the greatness and see it so I'm like
would it be better to achieve a lot of
greatness
uh and feel it or achieve greatness and
feel it or like maybe even less
greatness but actually feel something or
more brightness never feel it I'm like
I'm not really sure what's better I mean
I think I yeah I think the
achieving
less greatness and being able to
actually feel it would be better I mean
I've achieved incredible things so of
you and it's like if you're if you're
not living in it if you're not absorbing
it then it really doesn't mean
[ __ ] like like if you can't appreciate
it this is just a game of perception
like the human existence is just game of
perception there's a great guy named
Kashif Khan who owns a company called
the DNA company and he does he sort of
analyzes your DNA and is able to tell
you from all different aspects of of
your Wellness what
um what where you are good where you're
bad where you need to work on things
um so uh that could be a really cool
thing is that the guy Mindy knows yeah
yeah yeah yeah I I have the test here I
mean that's like what on my list of
things to do so great because you know
something like you were talking about
dopamine I have the highest amount of
dopamine receptors genetically you can
have so everything brings me joy
everything which I had to switch brains
for a day we blend them together I feel
like I don't want to give you mine can I
just take yours for the day
I'd love to trade it in for a little bit
more feeling a little bit more
um but you know something like that or
or or just whatever other genetic things
it's such a cool test and it's so so
such a thing of the future I think so
many people will do
um but okay cool you should definitely
do it and next up um so what do you like
what
what do people not understand about
anxiety
it's not it's something that I feel is
very complex especially for women
because I know like if my progesterone's
low
I literally I told my husband it was
like two days ago I was in right after
ovulation
estrogens drop big and I'm like I looked
at him and I'm like if you could be in
my head right now
it's like hell I was like it's like hell
like when your progesterone you know I'm
gonna make enough progesterone like my I
get body anxiety to wear everything and
he vibrates it's like someone plugged me
into a wall socket and it is no matter
what I do I can breathe I can meditate I
can do all the things but nothing works
and I think
you know there's all these tools that we
have and at some point sometimes nothing
works and I think the people around us
have to be compassionate to that
um because there's just some days that
you know there's so many like I said so
many components there's hormonal
component there's
um you know if I'm really triggered by
something you know that from trauma um
which seems to be for me now I think my
anxiety is definitely
um there's a there's a more
there's a physical component to it as
far as like like I said hormonally I
think
um is a huge piece for me that that
definitely um exacerbates the problem
so yeah I think I think people don't
realize
how layered and complex
anxiety can be and how many different
triggers we can have you know what can
be triggering it because there's there's
so many layers to it what's the best way
to love someone through that
foreign
oh
let it I I appreciate it when my husband
allows me to verbalize it and let it be
um and not try to fix it but just it
just sees me like you know that I can
say in my mind is a freaking living hell
right now and he's okay with it and it
it doesn't
we can still go about life but I'm just
and I think that's really it's good for
me to be able to verbalize it too
um so you know I don't feel like I'm
trapped in my own hell because I think
for a lot of people I I I'm sure a lot
of people relate to that for me it feels
like I'm trapped inside of a cell and
um
if I don't express to people what's
going on around me it Feels So Lonely
yeah so I think you know just allowing
for that person to express what's going
on inside is for me it's really helpful
and cathartic because it as soon as I
vocalize it
it's like the elephant just got you know
is now out of the room and yeah
um there's some space around it well
anxiety correct me if I'm wrong is kind
of isolating in and of itself like it's
a it's a mental Loop so if you're
already kind of in your head and then if
you can't verbalize it's like really
isolating yeah absolutely for me
sometimes the the body anxiety can be so
intense and it's and then all of a
sudden I will get in my head about just
the fact that I can't control what's
going on
um so
you know accepting acceptance is huge
knowing that
I do have tools
um and knowing that it will pass like
that's one been one of the biggest
things for me
I know everybody's like oh everything's
temporary and my mind goes to yeah but
how long is it gonna take
how long is this Gonna Last and now it's
like okay I can ride this wave and you
know I think that acceptance is huge
because I I have started to notice that
it really it really is a wave and it
will it will come and it will go
um I Heard I've heard you talk about
dancing before is that and like exercise
I've heard is a really good thing like
getting the body to move and kind of
blowing off some of the energy through
movement but I think somatic uh healing
is is really also along with EMDR I feel
like are really some very powerful
modalities that I think will become more
and more common so
um do
I was just at this I was just at this
festival and we did
um they called it fluent body and I kind
of wanted you to think it was maybe yoga
but you really just sat there and you
just sort of flailed your body around
for an hour and let me tell you I get
why dancers are fit AF because
um it was a lot of work
um but you know just being able to move
your body and like use like voice and
sound uh do you do that stuff yeah
absolutely sound is so powerful
um and you know it's totally a thing in
your voice like hello yeah but that's
what I was gonna say it's so interesting
because I
I've always used my voice for other
people and it was the last place I went
for myself
and so I that's why I started chanting
you know and and now one of the
practices that I do is I'll just go make
sound I don't need it to sound pretty
because you know all my sound usually
comes out sounding pretty and I usually
I'm controlling it in some way and I
think I love that you talk about
flailing your body around it's so nice
to just let our bodies and our voices
move and have movement and create sounds
because
I think there's so much freedom and just
the expression of the energy that wants
to come through us and not
focusing on how it has to look and for
someone who's been so much in the public
eye my whole life and I've been so
concerned about how I look and how I
sound
it's such a freeing experience and it's
really uncomfortable I can honestly I'll
go up and do it maybe for like three or
five minutes but past that I'm like I'm
really uncomfortable it it I can't get
out of my head about it but I'll allow
myself those few minutes to do it I've
gotten to where I can do it a little bit
longer here and there but
um
it does it bring up yes oh my God I can
be dancing to a really joyful song and
just bawl my eyes out because it's the I
that the freedom that expression without
control it goes back to the child like
the child who thought that I had to
control everything
um there's so much grief there actually
and so to touch upon that grief it's
like I can like dip a toe and then like
come out of it
um but I've I've I've held myself there
in moments where I've just let it
overtake me and it's um it's a powerful
practice it really is have you ever
heard of Taran Toomey
um it's a great it's a it's a work out
it's not crazy workout but it's a little
bit of a workout
but it's like 45 minutes to an hour and
you just like play one song there's one
song that plays and you just do the same
movement through it and eventually
sometimes you add like
like like your breath and stuff to it
um and then they do a hard opening at
the end and I would say about 80 of the
time that I've done one of the classes
um I've like for sure shed a tear or
cried or had some big
but it's this cool blend of being able
to just move your body for a for
physical you know activity and strength
and flexibility but then also pairing
that up with the voice and stuff and
music and the verbal prompting that they
do with you like what's in there what
are you coming up against like what's
the story you're telling yourself all
that kind of stuff just starts to like
really ruffle it up I don't know which I
like it it just came to mind because I
feel like I've had so much cool stuff
come through that I'm gonna have to try
that what was the other thing you were
you said you did at the festival yeah uh
oh it was called fluent body but it was
it was I'm not really sure if that's
like a class that you can do I think
it's just this sweet I think she was
maybe Italian I'm not sure but she was
about it okay leading leading us with
music and you know kind of allowing us
to flail around sometimes really
vigorously sometimes really soft right
sometimes with their eyes open we we
gazed at each other it was six girls and
at one point in time were literally dead
panning staring at each other and you
know that kind of stuff that kind of
stuff that's fun you love dancing though
right I feel like I've heard about it
yeah so that's no that's been a real rub
for me like a place where I've been
really uncomfortable I used to dance as
a child and then I don't remember who it
was it doesn't really matter but someone
told me that I was a better singer that
I was a dancer when I was young and it
kind of stunted that piece of me
and also growing up in front of the
public eye and like I said you know
people wanting to keep you a kid and
then they're growing into your own body
as a woman and
and then being sexualized and it was
just I kind of was like I don't feel
comfortable in my skin and dancing with
all of that
um
just felt yeah it felt like very
uncomfortable and so that's been one of
the areas like I said where I've really
uh I really learned to to be gentle with
myself and like I said if I get in there
for one song it's like okay I that's an
edge for me
so I want to hear about I want to hear
about them you know some point down the
line when you're like I dance naked for
an hour and there was a mirror and I
would like you know it's funny because I
I love I love the full moon and I I
literally have a deep desire to like go
out naked under the full moon and dance
so I think I think I need to I think you
saying that is my cue to like do that
next time speaking things into existence
I mean there's something obviously
happening in the quantity I'm curious
your thoughts about it like the fact I
don't know if it happens to you but
sometimes it does like something like
that that you have that thought about
doing that but I have no idea why I said
that I don't really know why those words
came out of my mouth but this field
around us is holding all the information
and I sometimes think that that's the
information from the field just sort of
coming into my awareness and some level
that feels like mine but it's not mine
it's in the field and it's partly it's
it's something to do with our
conversation
um but it's uh it's it's it's it's it's
fascinating to think about how much we
don't know is going on oh yeah it's
insane and I think it's beautiful like
we're all Messengers for one another I
mean I think that's why relationship is
so important because
uh and I I like this is why I love these
conversations I end up walking away with
something like that
and I think if you're open
as a Creator we're all creators um but I
also you know I'm such a it's creativity
is such a huge part of my job and
writing and
creating and so I'm constantly open to
life like I'm constantly looking and
listening and
um for inspiration and so I'm really
I feel like I'm really tapped into that
you know once we once we open ourselves
up to
to all of the signs and things that come
into our awareness
I feel like it's it's there all the time
you know and I mean it is there all the
time it's just once we open ourselves up
we we now have we're focused you know
our focus is is we're receptive to it so
um yeah I find I get messages all the
time from
from conversations and billboards and
whatever I may come in contact with and
um oh yeah I'll even listen to songs
sometimes that I've listened to a
gazillion times and all of a sudden a
line will pop out that's
you know that I hear differently and I'm
like oh that's the message it's you know
I guess it's I kind of Wonder is it is
it the universe talking to us or or are
we are we creating it are we making
meaning of it and I I think it's kind of
both ends
um because we are the universe so I
guess we're talking to ourselves really
um so I uh yeah I feel you I think
there's so many times something like
that will happen where you kind of like
don't know why you're saying something
and and it'll it'll instantly resonate
with someone and I think it's so
beautiful I mean that's that to me like
that mysterious piece of life I think is
so cool
you grew up Southern Baptist isn't that
right
religion and then there's spirituality
and I mean I don't know if they're
different but I would call them
different
um would you
yeah for me spirituality is my own
relationship to something bigger than me
um an organized religion is once again
it's kind of that inward to outward
um piece I feel like uh
I feel like the organized religion
there's there's a I love the teaching of
so many religions I think are beautiful
they're actual like essence of them
um and I I've learned so much from
from religion uh and
um
I feel like my own connection with
you know God Universe my own
spirituality and how I allow it to flow
through me into this world is the most
powerful
connection to have I was just wondering
if there was sort of like a point in
time where you felt like you were torn
between these sort of like the ideology
of religion and the and you know the so
many of so many so much of the weight
that comes with it shame and being wrong
or being too sexual or objectified or
any of those things and if there was
like a transition point where you were
able to recognize that box
that religion has and then
what it looked like to step into
something different that was hopefully
perhaps maybe more freeing or
um
uh accepting
um and had different a different
framework than yeah did you grow up
really religious I did my my mom was
very religious
um
and I had from the time I was like six I
used to have arguments with my mother
about like this makes no sense like
certain parts of this like why why are
only a hundred and something thousand
people going to heaven but there's like
millions and millions of people on this
earth like why is everybody else so bad
like that fundamental piece of it I just
could not wrap my head around I'm like I
don't I just don't believe that and
um I ran really far away from it and
kind of just exploding like didn't felt
connected I think I probably felt more
connected
to Seoul to to God through through music
um that was you know the most instant
way for me to experience that connection
um and then at 30 I think is really when
I started to I started to do breath work
that was kind of my first into
experiencing
um
gosh I guess self like a deeper deeper
piece of self to Soul
um to where I was really conscious I was
starting to become conscious of that
connection and so from that moment on
um the last 10 years it's really been
unwinding and undoing so many
yeah so much toxicity around like you
said sexuality
um you know original sin you know all
the things and you know my album I mean
God's work my new album is like
literally that's what it was that was
them doing like that was
um I talk about so much of that on the
record and so it um and that's the thing
like I'm really of the mindset like to
each their own everybody finds their own
way and I have no
it's I have no
um ill will or you know against any
anything or anyone when it comes to
religion I I just I choose differently
and I think my own love of for myself
has been more freeing
um than anything and
like I said that that internal
um that internal knowing I I was so
connected we all are as children to our
inner voice
so connected and then you know so much
it's
put on to us from you know our parents
and society and we lose that connection
and so for me these last 10 years have
really been about coming back home to
that connection and that being the
driving force for
for my own spirituality and my own life
do you think that you're kind of the way
you know your music tied you to a little
bit more of that religion just being a
little you know more country a little
bit more keeping you kind of Tethered to
that image you know when you're kind of
coming to this you know Spotlight as
like America's sweetheart it's you know
people people really have that image of
you and then you're like but this I I
can be I can be a sweetheart but that's
not all of me like and you start to like
you know we all we all wear a mask to
some degree
um until we become aware of it and
decide to take it off and for me like
you know being authentic and
recognizing that mask and all the the
um
everything I was trying to uphold for
other people or for for the world
um and their expectations like as soon
as I started to let that go uh
you know it just it feels like a weight
has come off my shoulders it's
you know to to be authentic and allow
you know all the like I say the
complexities of me to to be present
um it's been hard I mean I
I think I I used to feel so
other like superhuman in so many ways I
never had stage fright like it never
never thought about it and then
I guess my mid-20s you know when I
started or late 20s when I started to
allow that Mass to fall I realized I've
started to really recognize my humanity
and which is at first it's like oh [ __ ]
like I'm this is I don't have that armor
anymore and how am I supposed to be
superhuman and also human at the same
time and uh there's so much fear that
came up there and then
I started to allow my Humanity like I
started to
allow that to inform not only my life
but my art and
it
I feel like now I can walk into a room
feeling knowing
how great I can be and also knowing how
vulnerable and and fragile I am and
allow all of that to express itself
whether in an interview or whether on
stage like I found I find that that is
that is the superpower
to allow all of you into the space
that's vulnerability because most people
I died right they're like oh I'm gonna
be tough or I'm
um I'm the soft delicate one so I'm not
going to be telling them you know or
whatever it may be or I'm not going to
cry because that's weak or
um I'm not gonna be goofy and dance
around because I'm being bad and I
should be doing what I'm supposed to be
doing since the title of the album is
God's work
um
what is God I think it's that field and
I think we know it
or at least I have my experiences that I
know God when I allow it to work through
me when I'm receptive to it
um
I think we are I mean I say that I don't
know like we are God's work and it's you
know we are we are creation itself and
we are creators and
um
and right relationship to that I believe
you know we are
We Are The Vessel to be worked through
and so I feel like
the receptivity of that field
um
that everything is created from
I feel like that field is gone
I don't think I've ever thought about it
that way but when you said field earlier
I was like yeah that's it that's the
that that and it's always you know it's
always there
um it explains omnipresence yeah the
field totally it's not like some guy
that's up in a cloud sitting on a throne
no it's like oh hang on I got a call I
gotta go down it's like Brett's just an
enter I I I think of it it's energy
that's why when you said field I'm like
yeah and I think it's a it's a certain
frequency as well it's like it's for
those magical moments of transcendence
in a meditation or in breath work or in
a relationship or maybe when someone
meets their baby and they give birth or
whatever it is there's some some
frequency that's beyond our normal
frequency
it's not inaccessible it's just hard to
always be there because it's not there's
so much that pulls us down here in this
reality well human I mean I mean that's
why we're here right though too and I
you know to experience everything else
because otherwise I feel like we are
we are that frequency and so we'll
return to it
um I believe but
exactly exactly but first you gotta go
into the wild
of course exactly exactly well that's
the thing I feel like I feel like I went
through such a period of time where I
did connect with that well when I
connected with it so intensely
I don't want to return I don't want to
return and then I'm like you know but
there's so much there is so much
goodness here and you know we we get all
the flavors you know we get all the
flavors here and I think being able to
ground in this humanity and still access
that and then bring that here is kind of
I feel like that's kind of the game I
mean
really I mean I that's I and like when I
when I know I'm in that I mean I feel
like we're in that now actually like I I
feel like when you were talking about I
got chills I was like oh I and to me
that's I know I've touched into
something that's important and um
when you can bring that through you
it's such a beautiful thing like that to
me is that's Joy To Me
when you said in in the field and when
you started speaking about God my whole
body got goosebumps yeah that's always
such a sign that that it's like
basically to me the universe it's the
knowing frequency is saying yes yes
this is true there's such a mission to
sort of
um evolve Consciousness to bring
worldwide peace to
um live in joy and joy and Elation or
always be happy to some degree
but I question and we were you were just
starting to sort of really kind of get
into that so that's why I thought we'd
take a little bit of a dive in a little
further
I really question what is innate to our
human reality like what what is this
game that is just not going anywhere and
without it it wouldn't be the same and
it wouldn't we wouldn't have you know
the more pain I feel the more joy I feel
too like there's there's a polarity
within me that expands with my
experiences and
um
I wonder from your perspective with all
this sort of spiritual
um positive movement what do you think
is really needs to stay that's
challenging as far as being a human
oh I think it all I think it all stays I
don't think anything gets completely
excavated
um I don't think there's an end goal
um I think it all is
it all is purposeful
um do we have to suffer as much as we do
probably not
um
but I feel like it's all purposeful and
it's
I mean could you think about like never
feeling pain again
like that's kind of
if I did never feel pain again I that's
sad to me have you did you there was a
great show called
um the good place
with
um Kristen Bell and Ted Danson and
anyway it was basically about going to
heaven and when they actually really did
make it to heaven I'm sorry if you
haven't watched it but you want to
when you really get to go to heaven
there you got everything you wanted
immediately at the any you thought about
it and a door would open and you're in
Paris you thought about it and you'd
have an ice cream cone in your hand and
everybody was kind of like brain dead
muted when they got there because
there's no when you can have everything
that you want at any point in time
there's no negative emotion
um like you just there's no no purpose
like there needs to be there needs to be
a transition at some point in time or a
challenge at some point in time so once
they got given the doorway to be able to
fully exit and return to essentially
um Source or the ethers or to a
frequency they gave purpose to their
life and they started checking off the
list of all the cool things that they
wanted to do in the world and so if we
just lived happy all the time how would
we know happy without it it's like
exactly like meditating on death it's
like if you didn't die what value does
life have so if you have pain what value
would joy have and and love and
happiness if you didn't because you
don't know the opposite it's like
contrast contrast seems fundamental to
the universe oh I believe so absolutely
and it's um yeah that's so powerful I
mean I just just to think about not
having
I mean pain has
not that it it's the only thing that's
informed my life and my art but it's
such a huge part of it and the
connection of You Know The Human
Experience like I you know
to touch on spaceship you mentioned that
um I you know released that song in that
video recently and
um the the stories that have been shared
with me
from people about their own depression
and their own loss is so it's been
overwhelming and it's just you know when
you touch into the human connection or
Human Experience like that and it
connects people so deeply
um you know to have that
to have the array of those emotions
um
you know for me as an artist like I
couldn't even imagine being without it
like it's it's where I draw everything
from you know from
from Joy and and pain hope and
sensuality and to rage like it's just it
is um
it's all the colors to which you know I
paint the canvas with so it's
it's such a huge part of of our humanity
and so I think um yeah I don't think the
purpose is to ever rid ourselves of any
of that
um I think you know for me it's just
like how much
how can I how can I follow with it all
and do I have to sometimes the suffering
I feel like is when we you know latch on
to for me with my negativity bias those
like really darker heavier emotions and
I don't let go of it and so
it's it's been for me learning about how
to allow it to move through me and also
to move with it and then when Joy comes
not being afraid of it because I'm
afraid I'm gonna go back into that pain
you know so it's um
for me like just the allowance of of Joy
has been really challenging because I'm
so afraid to touch it because I know
eventually
it changes into something else and so
just that flow is a constant practice
for me I just had something come through
and tell me if this resonates
um where
it feels to me like
a lot of music is written through pain
and especially I think some of the most
powerful music and I have this belief
that music but anything but music is an
easy one to use in as an example because
it invokes emotion
um but not all of it does the stuff
that's true and the stuff that's real
carries a certain frequency and energy
absolutely that resonates as opposed to
something that's written for someone
that didn't have it's just kind of words
as like a arrangement of words that
rhymes and makes sense whatever it tells
some kind of a story but there's not
necessarily so much of a deep like
emotional truth truth imprint to it so
it feels to me like there's a lot of a
lot of a lot of amazing stuff comes
through the pain and that essentially as
an artist your your gift to people is is
the pain but the gift is through the
pain but the gift is connection because
yeah through that emotion you're
literally connecting yourself to all
these people so as you talk about
spaceship and how many great stories
have come from it now you're not alone
anymore you're not just it's not just
wanting to jump on the spaceship because
you feel alone you're like wait a second
holy [ __ ] there's a lot of people that
feel like this so through your pain you
you go through like the highest pain and
perhaps some of the highest Joy because
you can you now are connected and
plugged in to so many people and and
connection and Community is also I think
fundamental like I we operate like cells
in a body we're all in coherence and
we're working and we're fully functional
and we're together everything's going
great you split off and bad things
happen so okay that that kind of is what
came through and I just think I just
want to say thank you because like the
uh bravery to go through not only the
feeling but then putting pen to paper
and like actually
giving words to it then to yeah I mean
I'm giving words to so many experiences
and it helps me feel less alone like you
know loneliness has been such a key core
part of
I think all of our experiences If we're
honest but I you know for me it's it's
been
it's been something I've struggled with
for a long time and music has been my
way to connect to communicate and
um you know my Benchmark of success
these days is did I move someone and you
know when I
when I see people I mean I'll cry
thinking about it when I see that coming
back at me it was like
yeah that's that's why I do that and and
you know I I thought the other day I'm
I'm like I'm no longer I don't feel like
I'm a singer anymore of course I am but
at the same time I feel like
I feel like I I am a I'm a communicator
I'm I'm I am a you know I'm someone who
heals myself and helps others heal and I
feel like music is just one Avenue in
which I do that through and I think you
know I I used to
put all my eggs in that basket and it's
like I sing and it's like well no that's
just a frequency in which I used in
order
to help other people and so you're right
I mean there's so much there's so much
art that is created you know for
but people are in there for the money
and it's like it's it's you know we're
creating and honestly to numb people out
a lot of the time and you know sometimes
sometimes my music can be a little hard
to swallow these days because it doesn't
numb you out like it puts you in it and
um you know there's there's plenty of
artists on throughout you know all forms
of art that sometimes we need that and
it serves its purpose but I think for me
I know where where I stand and who I
want to be as an artist and that's
that's someone who helps people you know
feel so
um it's a gift it's a gift and
I'm I'm grateful to be able to
to have that gift in this lifetime it's
a it's a really cool gift
it's a big gift it's a it's a
yeah it's a big gift and it carries a
lot of
a lot of challenges too yeah um I love
this idea that as we're talking about
sort of like feeling and connection
um like a healing game it's it's an
inside job right I mean you can't you
can't fix anyone nobody can fix you
necessarily
but I do love
this
framing an idea that we are hurt in
relationship
so our ultimate healing comes in
relationship
um so I'm curious about some
relationships in your life that you feel
like have healed original wounds
I'll have to say Mindy's probably one of
my biggest relationships
um that has helped heal wounding for me
um just to have a woman in my life who I
think fully fully sees me and
um that is has been there for me through
this whole healing journey and this new
chapter of it
um she's just incredible human being and
so that's been I love her she's awesome
um I would say that she's been one of my
biggest as a newest you know as a preset
um I think my husband has been a huge
healer for me
um
once again someone who sees me someone
who's seen
oh the worst moments of my life and
still up to me and I like I still to
this day I'm like the little
the one the the piece of me that still
doesn't love all of me will ask him do
you love me like and you know and it and
when I do that I go oh I know I'm not
loving myself like that instantly I'll
go I it's not even a question you need
to answer it's a question that I need to
answer and so
he has he's really provided you know a
loving space for me to get messy and
pushes all the buttons and triggers of
of my life you know and that's what's so
beautiful is that we've committed
staying in it like you know it's so easy
when in relationship you know all those
triggers get triggered and they're like
oh I'm out and so I think we both really
we've been doing a lot together
and we both really committed to staying
in those moments and my manager who's
also um one of my best friends and my
creative partner Daryl Brown who created
the whole record with me
um he's been incredibly healing for me
and my my assistant
um who works she's part of my management
team
um she's also been incredibly healing
for me like I have these relationships
around me that are very healthy and I've
you know a lot of my relationships have
been because I've been you know I'm
constantly working I have these kind of
combined relationship of business and
and friendship and I've had many
um
I've had many relationships fall apart
because of that because that I didn't
know how to handle it and how to set
boundaries and now I feel like I'm
having I have these opportunities with
these incredible people in my life who
were all setting we all set healthy
boundaries we can support each other in
friendship and a business and it's
giving me the opportunity to do like all
of the beginning of my life in business
like all over again in a new way
and so that's been that's been beautiful
to and that's part of me stepping into
my Womanhood too you know it's like oh I
don't have to be afraid of these
relationships I can I can't have them be
multifaceted and it all stems from how
I'm holding myself in the relationship
and how I
you know and willing to show up willing
to set boundaries willing to know my
needs
um and express those and yeah it's um
I'm learning relationships are hard for
me like very very hard for me um but I
if I if I think about my list of all the
ways in which I've grown
how old were you when you started again
I was 11 when I got my record deal and I
was 13. almost when blue came out years
of
going going so yeah okay what where do
you see yours like where do things move
forward what lights you up I've heard
that you love learning like I love
learning maybe a certain Mindy told me
to
um yeah and I understand that obsessive
um insatiable uh drive to consuming and
understanding and you know whether it's
getting healthier being smarter or
whatever it is uh I I have I have that
too so where does it go because I feel
like I feel like where you're at in your
life and with this album and with the
SIM some how symbolic it is for you to
sort of
or get free
um is what it feels like I'm using these
are my words
um and so many different aspects because
there's so much so much variety of
messaging within the album and so much
different sound within the album even
um like this is where you from here on
you just you only do what you want to do
like that's what I asked for you very
strong is that the only thing that you
do from here on out lights you up and so
what where what are some of those things
like what are your secret hobbies that
we don't know about that might take
shape someday in a different way I
create candles actually
um I do I create candles and they're all
frequency based so I yeah I actually
chant over the candles and we record
chants at specific frequencies and as we
play them over them as they're drying
and so that encodes it into the wax and
so it becomes this whole yeah I had this
Epiphany one one day like in the middle
right the beginning of covet actually
and I was like that was before that a
couple years before that and I I'm like
this I was reading so much on frequency
and yeah how everything's frequency and
how everything can be affected by
frequency and I'm like wait
I could maybe and I love candles I love
smell like scent is it's such a game
changer for me a state changer and so I
am
I just had this idea one day that I
could create and you know waxes all
records are just a wax mold and so
really it's yeah records are like the
the original you know printing of that
is just a wax mold and so basically
you're recording sound into wax and so
it's like how could I incorporate all
this so I've been I play I've been
playing around with it for a few years
and I really want to get that like the
business up and running next year we
throughout coven that's basically what
my husband and I did was create candles
and I stopped this year for a moment
because
um you know just been so busy and but
I'm I really want to get that up and
running and it's it's super fun I love
creating a fragrance for it it's just
it's a blast so I I think that I also
one of my gifts is is sent and so I and
I love blending random stuff together
that no one would ever blend together
and it's um it yeah it's like to me
senses is like like music and so I love
it it like gives me yeah it gives me
feel it's like a feeling
um so yeah that's one of my little
hobbies and I you know I I have a real
purpose I think with my music and it's
you know I think this album speaks so uh
much to that purpose of of helping
people feel and you know
um and moving people and moving myself I
mean I've gone I've recorded music that
I don't even sing anymore sometimes
because like I did that because someone
wanted me to and it's I I promised
myself I think in my late 20s I would
never do that again and and that's just
like you know expanded but it is about
creating
things that you know help help to touch
people and I'm working I did a chant
record in 2020 and working on my second
chat record now
um I don't know I don't know where it
all goes I mean I think
like I said I think that music is just
one Avenue for for what I you know want
to help people with
um you know I have my podcast that I dip
in and out of I yeah
um I love talking about this stuff thank
you uh I love talking about this stuff I
love you know I'm sure I'll do
like if for as much as I
for as much as I speak on stage is
public speaking is terrifying for me but
I know it's like it's the next thing
that I want to do
um by the way yeah speaking engagements
where it's just q a
yeah that's a good thank you for saying
that maybe I'll ease in that way yeah um
I did a I did Lewis Lewis house had an
event that I did
um he wanted me to come speak and uh
he's like well just just come I want you
to like push your boundaries I want you
to do like just speak for like 10
minutes and then we can do a q a I'm
like okay I can do that perfect so um I
did I went and and once you get me
talking I don't shut up and I've learned
and I also chanted like I did this whole
speech into a chance and had everybody
chant with me and then we did a q a it
was so fun and after that I I was so
high after that from that experience I'm
like oh that I need to be doing more of
this so it will happen yeah yeah yeah I
gave you the yes yeah cool well we'll be
watching and smelling thank you yes yes
I love it well congrats on everything
congrats on the new album congrats on
the candle line that's on its way
because you've sent that up to the
universe and no penitent that I've sent
it out thank you for sharing like you
have a lot to share and a lot and your
your energy connects people
um not just through music but through
your words which is you know probably
what you're feeling on stage and and
what's happening in this interview and
then what's happening when people listen
to it it's uh it's really powerful so
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for having me
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button